monday
april 18th
the batman is now out on hbo max
everywhere
i've given the movie a shakedown and
managed to unearth every single hidden
detail easter egg and thing that you
missed in the film they think i'm hiding
in the spoilers i am the spoilers and
that's why i'm giving you your last
chance to make like gil coulson and head
off before we ruin the movie if you
enjoy the breakdown then please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day without the way thank you for
clicking the video i'm vengeance now
let's get into the breakdown okay so the
movie sees batman facing off against the
riddler who pulls heavily from a lot of
serial killers in both real life and
fiction this includes eyewitness
sketches of the zodiac killer who
appeared very similar to his design much
like the riddler zodiac had his own
symbol and he used to tone the police
and media with ciphers that detailed his
crimes beyond this there's also a lot of
horror icons that influenced the film we
opened with riddler watching the mez sun
and this first person view was also used
in the opening of halloween when he
later kills gil coulson the framing of
this whole scene is also extremely
aligned with the core mirror that
michael meyer does in his first film
matt resources stated that he took a lot
of inspiration from the opening scene of
the conversation which featured a virus
stalking people through binoculars
silence of the lambs also makes a big
impact when batman goes to arkham we see
that the shots are set up in a very
similar way to what happens when clarice
meets hannibal lecter for the first time
when batman first enters the mei's home
the police also stare at him in a way
that they did to clarisse when she
surveyed the crime scene in that film
now i might not look that intimidating
yet fair enough but the way that batman
is presented in the film is very much
like a horror villain he operates
similar to characters like jason
voorhees and like them he tends to walk
slowly towards his prey as an
intimidation tactic to let them know
there's no escape both the raila and
batman first appear from the shadows and
the pair are meant to marry each other
throughout the whole movie their
costumes have similar nose pieces they
of course wear masks they also keep
diaries and both spy on people using
binoculars now though he's a far cry
from the clownish riddler that we've
seen in films like batman forever there
is actually a nod to that film riddler's
clear frame glasses over his mask and
these look exactly the same as the ones
that jim carrey wore in that film he
very much riffs on batman earth 1 vol 2
in which he was a terrorist that placed
explosives around the city riddler would
challenge the police and batman to solve
his puzzles within a certain time limit
and if they didn't manage to he'd
detonate his traps now though we now
louie should i put on the v i'll not
bother putting on the voice now though
we encounter riddler in the mayor's home
in the opening scene of the film there's
actually a split second shot where you
can catch him just before this all
begins through his eyes we watch as he
surveys the home and when he looks up to
the roof if you pause the footage and
zoom in you can catch him in the
reflection of the glass really creepy
detail and there's actually another
moment where you can catch him hidden in
the scene at one point we cut to a wide
shot of the iceberg lounge and if you
look in the top left hand corner you can
catch edward sitting in his room taking
photos had batman thought about where
these photographs were taken from he
could have caught the character early
and we would have had about a five
minute long film yay ruining movies
other moments in the scene that are
important to look out for is the da's
suv which we can see down the road just
behind selena nation would have seen
this several times and he'd know that
coulson often parked there and that it
was a position he'd be able to strike
him from he ends up strapping an
explosive collar to his neck and this
actually pulls from a real-life bank
robbery that was documented in the
netflix film evil genius now other cool
details in the film or that we of course
meet his helper at the mayor's funeral
and he's the person that later on
announces that he's vengeance shortly
after this gil coulson is sent in and
his license plate reads
s397wd which is a reference to detective
comics 27 released all the way back in
1939. many of the officers in the movie
are from the 39th precinct as well and
like batman says it's all connected been
waiting to use that now during the live
stream there's also a comment that says
hope it's a dud and we've got to do it
all again tuesday which sets up the
attack that comes at the end of the
movie with the first killing happening
on october 31st we can work out that the
final one takes place on november 5th
which is likely a reference to bonfire
night on the 5th of november 1605 guy
fawkes took part in the gunpowder plot
in which he attempted to blow a
parliament had it succeeded this would
have completely destabilized the british
government more than partygate i think
reeves is very much giving a nod to that
with the date the live stream also has
some really nice puns in it such as a
user saying mind-blowing stuff and this
is gonna be such a blast
now much like me batman doesn't really
pay attention to the normal side of his
life he dresses a bit like a freak
sometimes which yeah kind of fair but
had he paid attention to the bruce wayne
side of his life he would have unearthed
the renewal project much much earlier
alfred tells him that it won't be long
before he goes burst and thus he calls
in the accountants bruce doesn't really
seem to care about this meeting but had
he paid attention to these books he
would have of course unearthed the
corruption within it that's why i make a
better batman now truth be told i love
this detail and it's something that's
popped up in a lot of early batman
stories both batman earth 1 and zero
year had him completely ignoring the
bruce wayne persona because he didn't
see it as being useful however at the
end of the comics he embraced it because
he realized it gave him another avenue
into gotham into which he could take
down the corrupt elite batman slowly
works his way up through the ranks in
the film and we watch as he starts off
with low-level thugs moves up to
gangsters takes down the person that
runs the entire city and then stops the
supervillain nice form of growth there
throughout and what
what's this what's what's this
riddle me this spoiler man
what does every heavy spoilers video
have in it that makes it awful
appalled in
[Laughter]
screen crash that right there
damn it riddler
i'll get you also in wayne manor we can
catch that he has an electric guitar and
an amp which was difficult to spot first
watch because this column was in the way
now selena also plays a big part in the
film there's a really subtle thing that
they do with her that actually shows
when she really likes someone and when
it's just an act initially she calls
annika baby and this is because she
cares about her a lot throughout the
rest of the film she calls everyone else
honey this even happens to bruce however
after they kiss she finally calls him
baby now the film culminates with the
sea wall of gotham being destroyed this
heavily pulls from books like zero year
which featured the riddler taking over
gotham after he flooded the city however
the riddler's plan in the film is also
heavily in line with the jokers in the
graphic novel the man who laughs in that
the clown prince of crime killed several
high-ranking politicians and he even
makes an attempt on bruce wayne's life
like what we have here come the end of
the work bruce discovers the joker's
plan to use the reservoir to take down
the city much in the same way that the
riddler does here now the sea wall being
destroyed is pretty much how the movie
culminates and we actually get a big
hint towards it early on in the film
during the debate with ballroom the
mayor says she wants to get their
renewal project fund which will mean
that vital seawall funds are also
cut opponent wants to gut the gotham
renewal program established by the great
thomas wayne cutting funds for vital
projects like our sea wall and the
safety net for those who need the
renewal program is broken going this
though we can catch a newspaper wall
chronicling dons wins and if you zoom in
on the one below the ellen lies you can
catch a mention of this and asks whether
the seawall construction has been
stalled and due to the greed of the
corrupting gotham it's turned it into a
weak point that the riddler exploits now
the movie opens with the title card in
big red writing and though this is
completely disconnected from wacky in
phoenix's film that too did something
similar i love this style for movies
that aren't part of the dc eu and if you
ask me might be better just doing these
standalone films warner brothers your
universe is a bit of a mess let's be
honest now the artwork used for the film
namely its posters and banners all
heavily used black and red imagery which
feels like it's based on the book dark
victory over the weekend i also started
binging through batman the animated
series and upon opening up the box set i
immediately recognized the title card of
that being in line with the movie too
riddler catches the mess son in a ninja
costume for halloween and their artist
is that he could end up being a robin
he's wearing red practicing martial arts
and he also finds his father dead kid is
clearly going to be traumatized yay and
guess what you're robbing now you punk
get in the costume chump and don't make
me tell you again now inside the mayor's
home we see a headline detailing
moroni's capture and in case you don't
know he's a gangster from the comics
that ended up throwing acid in hobby
dense face this happened during the long
halloween which this movie is heavily
based upon inner the killer known as
holiday strikes mobsters on every
holiday and he leaves clues behind at
the scene of the crime these attacks
completely terrify gotham and batman
harvey and gordon end up working
together in this year 2 story now it
even has a section where catwoman goes
off in her own and this expands into the
graphic novel catwoman when in rome in
this she attempts to unearth whether
falcone is her father or not but in this
film we already get it confirmed now
there's even a section that's ripped
directly from that book and when falcone
talks about thomas wayne saving its life
it's pulled from those pages he was shot
several times put on a table and
operated on whilst bruce sat looking
down on him this is very much murdered
in falcone's death later on and when
he's shot he lays on his back looking up
at bruce
what the what the hell was that hope
you've been watching this video legally
anyway after the riddlers attack we
cutted the bat signal lighting up and
they use color brilliantly here as we
start with green which is linked to the
riddler now he's very much infecting the
idea of what it means to be batman or
rather vengeance and it's very subtle
having his color be the thing that's
slowly breaking across the light that
shines above the city and what a city it
is
in our first wide shot we see the gotham
empire and the odyssey which may be
another book of the same name by neil
adams is also the bank of gotham and a
little caesars advert they ran a
promotion alongside the movie with a
batman pizza that looked
it looked like ass to be fair now
there's also signs up that say drops and
these appear on the train too though we
don't learn exactly what they are it's
likely that they're linked to either the
joker or potentially scarecrow the
former was caught before this movie
began and it could tie in with its
origin story at ace chemicals now over
the top of this seed we hear bruce's
chilling narration they think i'm hiding
in the shadows
but i am the shadows
we later learned this is part of a
journal entry and this somewhat riffs on
year one in which his narration was
presented in the form of notepads this
scene pulls heavily from bruce's first
night going downtown in which he dressed
up as a drifter and walked into the
centre of gotham looking to stop crime
several of the same shots and angles are
used and interestingly everyone around
bruce is in a costume however he's in
what would be class's normal clothes but
this is actually a disguise that he uses
in order to blend in so he's wearing a
mask much like those around him it seems
like it's always raining in gotham and i
think by the bat's signal and final
scene it pretty much is reeves said he
did this intentionally in order to add
to the detective noir feeling of the
film this was beautifully carried out in
blade runner and matt wanted gotham to
feel harsh and relentless almost like
it's beating down on you constantly in
every single aspect now we go to several
crimes across the city including the
good times grocery store robbery reeves
said that he chose to cast pattinson
because of the film good times which
this is clearly an odd two going beyond
that the drophead also wears the exact
same clothes at pattinson had on in that
movie and as i say
it's all connected and there are also
vandals messing up the bank of gotham it
is possible that one of these is anarchy
a low-level batman villain that uses
molotov cocktails and also spray paint
in order to send his message however who
batman is after is the black and white
gang that appears to be based on
penguin's goons from the comics and
games he made his forces wear the
colours black and white just like a
penguin and this design featured heavily
in arkham city they are trialling a new
member who only has half of his face
painted showing that he's not yet fully
part of the gang this actor plays robin
on titans and i did kind of get the
feeling that they were maybe trying to
show he was influenced by batman so this
could lead into something like the sons
of batman from the dark knight returns
batman stops them and they very much
represent random acts of violence that
have no meaning much like what took his
parents now it's at this point that he
introduces himself
i am wade no no
i'm vengeance this is a direct note to
batman earth 1 when the k crusader
introduced himself as that to the
penguin during the fight batman bursts
out a shocking attack which we know from
the book in the film is his taser glove
there was a similar power-up in arkham
origins which might be a reached out
speaking of arkham origins the batsu
feels like it's based on elements of
that however it also brings in certain
aspects of the suit from other
iterations the cow looks extremely
similar the one from gotham by gaslight
and this also had a color this appeared
in batman white knight and the darts on
the wrist are also something that the
talons used in the new 52 these were
used as assassins by the code of owls
and we also get a potential knot of
these in the first clue which has an owl
on the front of the card batman walks
through the scene with a strong focus on
his feet painting him out like he's
almost a character in a western movie
which is light and murdered at the end
of the car scene
now it's
hold on what's this
what's this
riddle me this
what do paul's wife and his subscribers
both say about him
he finishes quickly
goddammit riddler now it's at this point
we meet commissioner pete savage played
by the savage trevor from eastenders in
the comics it was commissioner love who
was murdered in the book dark victory
and they might have changed it up
because love was the commissioner and
batman begins throughout batman very
much disregards the bruce wayne side of
his life and he rides around the city on
a motorbike i feel the movie very much
also pulls from elements of batman year
100. this is a great graphic novel set
in the future in which batman rides
around gotham on the back of a custom
motorbike he's very much a mechanic that
also uses horror motifs from the movies
to scare his prey much like what
pattinson's version does now batman
returns to his base of operations called
wayne terminus this is revealed to be a
disused train station created by the
waynes similar to the monorail that they
built in batman begins having a train
line under the city would allow batman
to travel under it without going under
the surface and it's a strategy that
he's also used in the comics during the
nightfall arc john paul valley who took
over the cowl fitted his batmobile with
wheels that could run on train tracks
and he constantly run around on them
under the city bruce mounted bikes
similar to the one that he hadn't zero
yet and he rides past gotham square
garden which has bella real adverts up
at it this is where the final battle
takes place and we can see it showcasing
the upcoming election night bruce passes
by here later on when he's following
selena from her apartment and it slowly
teases this is a major location we catch
my boy has an emo haircut and though
this gets memed on a lot i actually
think there's a specific reason for it
in the new 52 bruce shaved his head so
it was one thing he didn't have to worry
about and maybe he grew along because he
doesn't care about his appearance or
have time to cut it bruce plays back the
night and he then juts down the
narration that we just heard at one
point we can see his contact lens also
creates a transcript so that batsy never
misses a trick bruce ends up looking
over his shoulder to the news
announcement and this shot is lighter
murder in the reveal of the riddler
hitting to us at how the two are linked
as alfred descends we can catch the
batmobile engine and the car itself sit
under a top we get shots of this lace
throughout the cave at several points in
the movie and it very much hints at its
reveal alfred looks over the video of
the child and clearly this reminds him
of a young bruce who he feels like he
failed now we get bruce coming out of
the shower and can see that he's got a
heavily scarred back this is a nod to
the alex ross piece of art which also
had similar cuts on it i love the camera
work here and throughout the film
there's several scenes where we follow
characters from behind such as gordon
selena and of course bruce lots of
feelings like we are voyeurs ourselves
and it very much adds to moments like
this now bruce has very much become a
nocturnal animal and upon seeing the sun
for the first time he has to cover his
eyes with sunglasses at this point we
meet dory who i kind of feel like might
be an odd to and harriet from the 1966
batman show we get a much clearer easter
egg that pulls from this later on when
we catch the shakespeare bust next to
alfred this was a big part of the show
and i love how reeves included it after
cracking the cipher they head to the
mayor's garage which is filled with
expensive cars gordon says i guess it's
good to be the mayor and clearly he
could only afford these if someone was
lining his pockets now during his search
batman bursts out a tube light which he
carried in the new 52 and also earth one
in the tire of an aston martin they find
the weapon used to sever the mayor's
thumb and a thumb drive with his thumb
attached to it
thumb drive
should have turned off wi-fi though
because activating it sends out emails
to everyone including the gotham gazette
a newspaper that's popped up in the
animated series in the new 52 black case
book and a lot more we get a split
second shot of gordon's inbox and this
contains several bureau memos that are
appeared however there's also the case
file 0-281 which might be not to batman
281 titled murder comes in black boxes
panicker very much feels like she's
based on holly robinson a character from
year one that catwoman lived with later
on in the batmobile chase we get a sign
for robinson park which also happens to
be a location in gotham based on her
batman then arrives at the iceberg
lounge which is the base of operations
for the penguin in the comics this scene
pretty much happens three times in the
movie with him first going as batman
then bruce and then he sneaks in later
having formulated the best strategy to
get in there without getting caught the
twins also feel like they're based on
the villains tweedledee and tweedledum
which my surnames twiddle yet i've just
had twins
they're gonna get called that and i i
bloody i'm fuming i tell you now batman
then goes in the club and i kind of
wanted him to bust out dad's moves come
on do the bat dance come on
also look at these funko pops yeah god
a penguin clearly isn't intimidated by
him as he calls him sweetheart but come
the car chase he's terrified it's clear
oz is just a lowly worker that no one
really respects and batman mocks his
reputation which i find hilarious batman
follows catwoman back to her apartment
and he ends up spying on her much in the
same way they looked over andrea in mask
of the phantasm
andrea he follows her to the mayor's
office and body pops his grappling gun
like it's a start of smooth criminal oh
also notice how bruce drops the batman
voice when talking to her as opposed to
how he interrogates the penguin now
selena attempts to get annika's passport
back in a scene that's somewhat riffing
on the long halloween in that selena
went to falcone's apartment to crack his
safe and batman confronted her there
before grabbing a ledger full of the mob
boss's dealings they then returned to
selena's apartment and in the comics
this was where they originally met now
the movie is filled with these news
reports that somewhat riff on batman 89
and also the dark knight returns
in those they were used to pretty much
tell us the story as well as the
opinions of the public on batman after
pete savage is killed we get our second
clue which has an old man on the front
and then an explosion inside of the cord
this might be foreshadowing the
explosion that happens later with alfred
as the following clue has a woman
answering the phone much like what
happens with dory on her way to the club
ception club within a club she comes
across william kenzie a character from
the comics that was also a gcpd officer
in the basement she meets d.a gil
coulson possibly riffing on gilda
javidan's wife was of course a d.a in
the long halloween there's also carla
possibly a not to call avidi who also
featured in that book i jump to the bat
signal scene and we get a hint at
renewal on one of the billboards which
is then shown when gordon pulls up
renewal is purposely laced throughout
every aspect of the city and it shows
how wide it stretches it even shows up
on the back of a garbage truck because
like you it's trash beside the signal we
see the wgot radio tower this was a
radio station in the comics that jack
ryder reported for we then get the next
clue this has a urso url
and they mess up the translation
occurred at the funeral and the external
shots were heavily shown online by
people that went to watch these scenes
being filmed reeves wanted to keep barry
keown's role of the joker so secret that
he actually filmed fake scenes with him
in which he seemed like a policeman
there were also several shots with zoe
kravitz and john tuturo that made it
seem like they had a relationship i kind
of hope that irving and severance is
actually his innie and this is his audi
but that's a crap little theory i have
go check out our severance video though
it's really good now bruce wright in a
corvette which was also used in the
1970s as a basis for the batmobile huge
shout out to the canadian lab for that
one and go check out his breakdown as
well now the explosion by riddler is a
big talking point around the movie as it
blasts batman in the face and he still
comes out looking like robert pattinson
his mouth isn't even burned and it does
seem a bit unrealistic
however if you slow down the footage yes
slow it well we will do it for you slow
down the footage and you can actually
see him putting his hand over his mouth
to cover it just as the bomb goes off as
a disclaimer yeah if a dude ever
explodes in your face make sure you
cover your both oh cut that
and the police started questioning
batman and we get this awesome scene
early on in his career the police were
very much against him and in both year
one and mask of the phantasm he ended up
taking down a whole swat team he ends up
gliding off the top of the police
department and smacks his face which is
potentially playing on the opening of
earth 1. in that he goes to jump across
the building but he ends up falling
after his grappling gun breaks the
penguin scene happens at the docks and
reeves stated that he took a lot of
inspiration for the batmobile from the
john cobb and a classic christine you've
done a full video on this scene alone
but like batman the car comes from the
shadows it also gets covered in fire and
chases after someone much like the
monstrous machine did in that movie
reeves stated that he took inspiration
from the french connection and also
elements of the steve mcqueen classic
bullet along with the robinson reference
there's also nods to hinckley river
which is a feature in gotham upon being
caught penguin waddles like one which i
absolutely love the scar across his face
also gives a beak-like shape to his nose
and i really hope that the makeup
artists behind this get an oscar because
colin farrell looks absolutely
unrecognizable now after tracking really
to an orphanage about batman and gordon
explore it much in the same way that the
pair went through an abandoned building
together at the end of earth one here
they see a campaign video for thomas
wayne and in that book the character was
running for mayor which led to his
murder he also ran for mayor and joker
but unlike that version of thomas this
one seems more sincere even if he does
like getting journalists beaten up now
again we hear the song ave maria which
opens the movie this is typically used
at both funerals and weddings and it was
actually one of john when gays's
favorite songs along with sen in the
clowns at this time it's sang by
children's choir and we later learn that
edward is a member of this group
explaining why he likes to sing it
alfred then gets a letter for the batman
and if i ever get male that has
fireproof on the back i'm i'm throwing
it away i don't care who it's from now
there's a lot of debate over whether
riddler knows bruce is batman or if he
doesn't in the comics during the hush
storyline he figured it out but he
decided not to tell anyone because of
how worthless a riddle is that everyone
knows the answer to hush is also
referenced in the film during the
campaign video and we see the surname
elia pop on screen thomas alia became
the villain hush in the comics but the
animated movie changed things up so that
it was actually the riddler under the
mask now potentially the riddler is a
journalist kid though we never get this
confirmed our clue that riddler might
know is that bruce is the only target he
doesn't try to kill himself therefore it
might be because he wanted him to
survive but i i'll leave that up to you
to debate in the comments you also learn
more about martha wayne who like earth 1
is revealed to be an arkham originally
she was called martha kane after bob
kane but they changed it up to kind of
give bruce the feeling that insanity
runs in his family now the wayne's cease
and desist leader demand is sent by the
law firm miller and moore which are nods
to frank miller and alan moore two
seminal batman riders batman goes to
falcone who will get hints towards
murdering thomas this is a slight change
here from earth 1 in which it was
suspected that penguin did it so that he
could become mayor revealed to be the
rat with wings all eyes and turn to him
now in every other iteration he's called
falcone but i think they change it up to
this to do the little falcon bird pun
now
what the hell is this
riddle me this
what happens when your spoilers are too
heavy for your tv
your screen
gets crushed and you
suck at breakdown videos quit while you
still can
screen crush god damn it i knew it was
your punk
wearing a shirt on my face
you got a little dick and your kids are
actually mine
[Applause]
now we're at the final hour mark of the
movie and selena ends up scratching
falcone's face and this is exactly the
same as how she did in yet one bruce
ends up leading falcone into the light
which makes the riddler believe that
he's an accomplice and an ally in on his
plan they catch him at a diner that pops
up throughout the film and the look of
this scene is based heavily on
nighthawks by edward hopper riddler's
head gets smashed against the counter
like you should smash that like button
and this cracks his glasses i love how
this detail remains on them for the rest
of the film and you can catch it in the
arkham interrogation he also carries two
ids edward nashon and patrick parker
which are both aliases that he's used in
the comics however we still don't have
his true name which is edward nigma or
mr enigma now inside the apartment we
catch a single bat in a cage with a rat
scurrying below it which represents
batman hanging above the city whilst the
rats act below him riddler's final plan
is located under his carpet but because
bruce comes from a privileged background
he doesn't recognize the class carpet
too he goes to visit riddler and arkham
and we know from the deleted scenes that
something similar happened with the
joker due to the one that was recently
posted in this batman handed over
evidence with a paper clip on it and
this later disappeared because the clown
prince of crime likely pocketed it
whether this will lead to is escape we
don't know but the pair do form a
friendship come the end of the movie
this could potentially set up a war of
jokes and riddle's sequel which turned
gotham into a war zone there's also
heavy allusions to no mansland from the
comics gotham was rocked by an
earthquake in the book cataclysm and
after the government abandoned the city
it turned into a wasteland with every
criminal vying for control covered in
the dark knight rises it seems like
they're setting up things with battle
royale potentially reaching out to bruce
so that he can help save things in the
comics he ended up traveling to the
senate to beg for help and this could be
what makes him realize he needs to pay
more attention to this side of his life
batman ends up taking down the riddler's
forces and though i was hoping that it
would be venom that he uses the official
book released alongside the film does
say that it's adrenaline there's also a
scene where he moves out of the way of
someone shooting him and though there
were a lot of complaints on twitter that
he just let this guy die if you slow
down the footage you'll see the bullet
actually hit his gauntlet and head which
then causes a ricochet he also ends up
clouding the whole area in smoke which
is reminiscent of the scene from the
dark knight returns in which he did the
same thing when fighting two faces
forces through the goon he realizes
batman must very much become a symbol of
hope and he goes through somewhat of a
baptism emerging as a new kind of hero
he's now seen as someone that people
shouldn't cower away from and this is
symbolized by the girl on the roof the
man at the train station at the start
was terrified of him or as she refuses
to let go showing how his ark has gone
from being above vengeance to something
more important flooded locations litter
the finale including city hall the diner
the iceberg lounge and we catch penguins
staring over the city we know that he's
getting a spin-off show very soon and he
will try and grab everything that he can
in his quest for power catwoman says
that batman's spoken for and this is the
line that ended batman's zero year she
also states that she's going to
bloodhaven which is a sister city to
gotham in the comics that's a hornham
nightwing batman rides off beside selena
and then watches her disappear in the
rear view mirror before turning his eyes
to the road he'd love to go with her but
gotham is way as hard as that and i love
how this shot is used to convey that
emotion come the end of his arc i'd love
to see bruce deciding to ride off with
her and getting a sort of similar scene
but sadly i can't watch the scene
without seeing this anyway thank you for
sitting until the end of the video i had
to record this twice because my camera
broke um i'm absolutely sweating i'm
drenched you can probably tell just by
looking at me i look a mess so a thumbs
up is massively appreciated also [ __ ]
binary and i'll see you on the next one
take care peace